[Musica]
la prima grande campagna marketing che
ho gestito da un budget di 9 milioni di
dollari Eppure Tutto è cominciato con un
oggetto che costava appena un euro un
oggetto semplice alla portata di noi
tutti che secondo me anche la chiave del
nostro percorso di evoluzione
quell'oggetto era ed è
una matita
di questo vi parlerò fra poco Intanto
però visto che siamo qui a parlare di
evoluzione una domanda per voi tutti
Dove sei oggi ovviamente non in termini
fisici vi vedo ma in termini metaforici
dove vi trovate nel vostro percorso di
evoluzione in quale punto siete in
questo preciso punto nel tempo oggi Io
ad esempio potrei raccontarvi che lavora
a Londra potrei raccontarvi che negli
ultimi 10 anni ho lavorato nel marketing
di grandi aziende startup potrei
raccontarvi che da un paio d'anni
Gestisco la mia attività che anche la
mia missione quella di aiutare altre
professioniste a crearsi un percorso di
carriera su misura per sé
questa storia però posso raccontarvela
solamente oggi e visto che siamo qua a
parlare di evoluzione Prova a portarvi
con me a circa 13 anni fa 13 anni fa io
ero ancora una studentessa
e nonostante questo nonostante non
avessi neanche iniziato il mio percorso
professionale mi sentivo tremendamente
in ritardo nella vita l'unica cosa che
sapevo L'unica cosa che sentivo è che
volevo fare un lavoro Qualcosa che
avesse un impatto nel mondo e nella vita
delle persone però non avevo idea di
come farlo né se ci sarei riuscita Ero
talmente in paranoia talmente impanicata
Su che cosa farò ce la farò ci arriverò
che ad un certo punto è arrivata
all'ultimissimo esame di economia ho
pensato No vabbè io basta mi fermo qua
mollo tutto oggi mi sembra quasi un
ragionamento illogico mi sembra il
pensiero di un'altra persona Eppure
all'epoca io lo pensavo davvero lo
sentivo davvero perché del resto era
quella la storia che mi raccontavo
avanti veloce a 7 anni fa sette anni fa
alla fine mi sono laureata due volte e
dopo qualche esperienza di qualche anno
in Italia decido di fare il famoso
biglietto di sola andata direzione
Londra a Londra altri dubbi altri
tentennamenti ma alla fine vengo a
scontato come marketing manager
all'interno di Google Google
quell'azienda che è un mio professore
all'università aveva definito come
l'olimpo dei migliori ok Vediamo che
succede in questo Olimpo arrivo il primo
giorno durante l'on boarding ci sono
tutti gli altri assunti di quella
settimana inizio a parlare arrivo
tranquillissima
Il ragazzo ha la mia destra mi dice sì
Io ho appena concluso questa NBA Sono
atterrato proprio ieri da Singapore Ok
ragazzo sulla destra Ciao vado a parlare
con la ragazza sulla sinistra
e lei mi dice sì Io mi sono laureata
Berkley ho fatto l'imprenditrice in
tutti questi ultimi anni adesso ho
deciso di tornare a farla dipendente la
ragazza sulla sinistra aveva 24 anni io
dico Ok ciao anche tu Io in quel momento
in mezzo a quelle persone
inizia a pensare Oh mio Dio ma io che
cosa ci faccio qui perché hanno scelto
me
perché sono qui Mi sento come la piccola
fiammiferaia sento tutte queste persone
attorno a me parlare guardo una pianta
di ficus dietro di me penso Ok se mi
nascondo lì dietro per la prossima ora
fino alla prossima pausa poi posso
scappare andrà tutto bene o un piano
perché in quel momento la storia che mi
stavo raccontando è che io non
appartenevo a quel Olimpo dei migliori
che io ero lì per sbaglio che io non
potevo essere lì insieme a quelle
persone che mi sembravano così in gamba
piccola digressione
quello che iniziò a dirmi è sicuramente
hanno fatto un errore sicuramente non
volevano assumere me ma Kimberly o
stencil un'altra ragazza dal nome
perfettamente Californiano laureata
Stanford Ma non è perché io qui non
appartengo e questa grazie alla regia
era un'altra storia che mi raccontavo
una storia piuttosto dolorosa
e quindi torniamo ad oggi
oggi
ma non ha la giusta slide Beh oggi siamo
qui oggi
Questa è la storia che posso raccontare
e lo so lo so che questa è solamente una
storia è la mia storia
ma nella mia storia se ripenso a tutte
quelle che ho ascoltato in tutti questi
anni da parte delle mie lettrici rivedo
la storia e il sentire le paure di molti
la paura di essere in ritardo nella vita
come se ci fosse una Timeline del
cambiamento e dell'evoluzione unica per
noi tutti la paura di prendere decisioni
sbagliate come se ci fossero decisioni
sbagliate oppure di apparire sbagliate
sbagliati agli occhi altrui fallabili
ok questa
non mi è uscita bene quindi direi
andiamo avanti la paura di non essere
mai abbastanza non abbastanza brava non
abbastanza competente
sempre qualcosa che non c'è sempre
qualcosa che non va O al contrario la
paura di essere sempre qualcosa di
troppo troppo giovane o troppo vecchia
troppo esperta o troppo inesperta Troppo
timida troppo aggressiva
la paura di non appartenere la paura di
non meritare certo opportunità certe
certi ruoli di stare in certe aziende
certi percorsi certi stipendi certi
ruoli Certi lavori certe Carrieri
addirittura di non meritare certe vite
Questa è la storia che ci raccontiamo in
molti
la raccontiamo noi stessi e poi la
raccontiamo anche agli altri come una
sorta di telefono senza fili in cui se
anche una chiamata una vocazione
iniziale c'era Alla fine è così persa e
così diluita
che del significato iniziale non rimane
più nulla Rimane solamente un eco Un
suono una storia senza morale
e quindi
come se ne esce come facciamo a
rispondere alla nostra di chiamata Come
facciamo a ridare significato e valore
ai nostri percorsi alle nostre storie
a me una soluzione la via di anni fa
proprio durante il periodo in Google la
mia manager e mentore dell'epoca fu
quasi una lampadina che si è accesa fu
una sorta di passaggio di testimone
qualcosa che io oggi voglio lasciare a
ciascuno di voi
Quindi adesso trasportiamoci a Londra Io
sono in col con la mia manager in questa
enorme sala riunioni lei è collegata
davanti a me da Berlino e mi sta
aiutando a rivedere il mio curriculum
per una posizione interna e mi dice
il tuo curriculum non dice la verità su
quello che hai fatto Io penso Oddio In
che senso e mi dice sì guarda che ti
stai molto sottovalutando
e lo capisco ti capisco perché anche io
mi sono sentita così e io penso
No no che non ti sei sentita Così anche
tu tu che hai un NBA che parli sei
lingue che hai vissuto in sei continenti
diverse che sei sempre cosa dire cosa
fare in qualunque momento non è
possibile che anche tu ti sia sentita
così E invece sì E quante volte in tutti
questi anni a persone
insospettabilissime ho sentito dire la
stessa cosa perché del resto questa
storia che certe cose le proviamo solo
noi è un'altra bugia è un'altra storia
che ci raccontiamo
e poi la mia manager raggiunge però sai
oggi la responsabilità e la scelta è tua
oggi tu puoi scegliere di entrare in
ciascuna stanza in ciascuna riunione a
ciascuna cena di lavoro raccontandoti la
storia di chi è di ieri oppure
radicandoti nella storia di chi sei oggi
ma soprattutto
proiettandoti nella storia di chi vuoi
essere chi vuoi diventare domani ed
entrare in ogni sala in ogni stanza in
ogni riunione raccontandoti quella
storia lì raccontandola te stessa ma
soprattutto raccontandola agli altri
Ok
la storia di chi voglio essere
la storia di chi voglio essere bello ma
che Martina la pratica questo concetto è
qualcosa su cui ho riflettuto molto e il
modo in cui voglio
comunicarvelo trasmettervelo oggi e
questo da quella sala riunioni in
Central Londra adesso ci trasportiamo al
mare ti chiedo uno sforzo di
immaginazione ci siamo ok qualche anno
fa ero in vacanza al mare in acqua sento
queste due bambine vicino a me che
giocano a Facciamo che Una dice
all'altra senti
facciamo che io ero una sirena ed ero
magica e avevo il potere di controllare
l'acqua e anzi no no avevo tutti i
poteri del mondo
l'altra bambina Poverina non aveva
nessun potere doveva solamente guardare
l'amica che faceva la sirena ok
E allora io le guardavo e da un lato
sorridevo però e dall'altro Mi chiedevo
Ma quando è successo
è successo che abbiamo perso la nostra
capacità di sognare e di immaginare
quando quando è successo che abbiamo
perso fiducia nei nostri poteri nelle
nostre capacità
perché Guardate che alla fine è solo una
storia quella che ci raccontiamo
e quando è successo che la nostra storia
è passata da Facciamo che abbiamo tutti
i poteri del mondo a Facciamo che
facciamo schifo Facciamo che non siamo
abbastanza preparate Facciamo che non
siamo abbastanza competenti che non
siamo abbastanza in forma abbastanza
pronte sempre qualcosa che non va sempre
un attacco all'estero sempre un attacco
a noi stessi e quando lottiamo contro
noi stessi c'è sempre una parte che
perde
sapete io me lo sono chiesta lunga Mi
sono detta arlinda vuoi davvero davvero
parlare di sirene nel tuo the decks
allora perché non della fatina dei denti
però alla fine tornavo sempre con la
mente col pensiero al ricordo di quella
giornata al mare perché se ci penso e da
quei Facciamo che che sono nate alcune
delle scoperte dell'evoluzione delle
rivoluzioni più importanti che abbiamo
avuto nel corso della storia cosa che
oggi diamo quasi per scontate facciamo
che
facciamo che
l'incipete lo stesso ma il finale della
storia lo diciamo lo decidiamo e lo
scegliamo noi
Facciamo che possiamo volare Facciamo
che possiamo parlare con qualcuno che si
trova dall'altra parte del mondo in
tempo reale Facciamo che possiamo
debellare per sempre certe malattie
Facciamo che anche le donne possono
votare e poi la mia preferita
Facciamo che queste nocciole possano
diventare Nutella
Grazie
un meritato applauso per la Nutella
facciamo che
E allora qui torniamo alla nostra matita
perché
vi ricordate cosa ci dicevano a scuola
ci dicevano che
per convenzione il passaggio dalla
preistoria alla storia
quella con la s maiuscola ma anche
quella con la s minuscola si fa partire
Con l'avvento della scrittura e ha
perfettamente senso Perché quando noi
scriviamo quando noi ci scriviamo di
fatto creiamo questa sorta di fil Rouge
un film Rouge narrativo che mette
insieme tutte le nostre esperienze tutte
le nostre emozioni tutti i nostri
pensieri qualcosa che restituisce senso
e significato a chi siamo e a quello che
facciamo qualcosa che ci connette che ci
fa rispecchiare e risuonare con le
storie degli altri
e basta una matita vedete io
nel mio lavoro in tutti questi anni l'ho
visto succedere tantissime volte ci sono
queste aziende alcune delle più
importanti e grandi al mondo che ogni
anno spendono decine di milioni di
dollari per fare cosa per scrivere
raccontarci delle storie
per dirci chi sono
per raccontarci perché dovremmo
scegliere Proprio loro
e se queste aziende fanno tutto questo
spendono tutti questi soldi tutto questo
tempo tutte queste energie per
raccontarci delle storie perché noi non
spendiamo lo stesso tempo e le stesse
energie è la stessa cura per scrivere le
nostre di storia
e si parte sempre da lì
da una matita
da un foglio bianco
e da una domanda
Quale storia scriverai
Grazie
[Musica]